بعد اجتماع للحكومه التركيه القى الرئيس
التركي خطابا في مجمع الرئاسي قدم فيه حجه
المتعلقه بالعمليه العسكريه المرتقبه شمال
سوريا والتي تستهدف قوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه وقوات حمايه الشعب الكردي رجب
طيب اردوغان قال ان قرار تامين الحدود
الجنوبيه لتركيا بعمق 30 كم اثبت جدارته
ولا يجدر ان يزعج احد كما اكد التزامه
بالقضاء على حزب العمال الكردستاني الذي
يعتبر ارهابيا في تركيا حتى تحيد اخر عنصر
فيها مؤكدا الخسائر التي تلحق بالكرد شمال
سوريا والعراق
بينما نتخذوا خطوات تتعلق بامن وطننا
وشعبنا فاننا لا ناخذ اذنا من احد ولا
نعطي اي حساب لاحد ليس علينا ان نتسامح مع
نفاقي اولئك الذين يدعمون المنظمه
الارهابيه التي تلعب بتغيير الاسماء يجب
على اولئك الذين يحاضروننا حول
الديمقراطيه والحقوق والحريه ان ينظر اولا
الى الارهابيين وانصار الارهاب في بلدانهم
تركيا القوات الكرديه عبر الحدود منذ
اسبوع قذف بريا وغارات جويه لاستهدف
كوباني او عين عرب ومنبج وتل رفعت شمال
سوريا في المرحله السادسه من تامين الحدود
التركيه والتي بدات عام 2015 ياتي هذا
القرار مع اقتراب الانتخابات التركيه
وتحسين العلاقات بين تركيا ومصر واحتمال
افتتاح تركيا على النظام السوري وزير
الدفاع التركي خلصي اكار اجتمع سابقا
بسفيري الولايات المتحده وروسيا لتذكرهما
بالاتفاقات الماضيه القاضيه بانسحاب
الكردي ثلاثين كيلو كان هذا في ما يتظاهر
الكرد شمال سوريا تمديدا بالحمله التركيه